la règle c'est de considérer que
l'exercice physique c'est qu'il pleuve
qu'il vente ou qu'il soit en été ou en
hiver il faut sortir ça il faut bouger
mais on peut pas assister nous qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire ici oui aujourd'hui sur
son bâbord
d'abord alors marcher ça suffit oui
parce que si on veut perdre un peu de
poids il faut mouiller la chemise à
bayon mouille pas la chemise en lin mais
sous un robinet avait souvent si vous
êtes entraînés vous pouvez le faire en
cardio classique d'accord soit si vous
n'êtes pas entraîner vous commencé
doucement il faut pas se faire mal être
ce qui est important c'est de faire
longtemps et pas il sert de fractionner
d'accord exemple vous fait vous allez
courir tranquillement bien couvert avec
un podcast la caste d'une émission par
exemple et puis vous courrez pendant
cinq minutes cool et puis pendant 30
secondes
ben hammam ou aller à fond accor et à ce
moment là c'est que c'est magique le le
muscle va commencer à sécréter des
peptides très particulier qui vont
libérer les graisses qui sont allées
très vite et aussi ses dettes et il est
très critique acceptons vous pouvez
aussi donc faire du fractionné faire du
continue malheureusement les piscines
sont fermées mais la piscine ce cas
mieux à ce qu'il me faut de très sales y
en a une chez lui donc sur ce tracé ou
non ensuite et en musculation
parce qu'il ya la musique a vu la
musculation
alors franchement que j'ai pas eu le
temps de vérifier mais on a montré que
utiliser mes biceps et les tristesses
avait une influence sur les sécrétions
du pancréas alors ça je vais vérifier
parce que c'est là un centre de
recherches de strasbourg s'émouvoir et
adrar faut faire de la musculation donc
faire voilà la musculation et surtout du
buste c'est extrêmement important
et puis il ya une autre une autre chose
c'est que il faut essayer de faire des
séances de respiration un peu de
respiration abdominale parce que ça
permet de masser son foie ce que le
grand patron de la régulation du sucre
dans l'organisme
c'est le foie c'est le foie d'accord il
faut pas que le foie gras d'accord
l'ipad qui soit gras manger des sucres
index glycémique plutôt bas c'est ce que
je fais c'est qu'ils regardent toujours
si le sucre et un index glycémique bas
et donc là alors donc les conseils donc
ces sports mais alors qu'il ya plein de
gens qui vont venir oui mon rôle c'est
ça mais rien n'y a pas et pourquoi ne le
font pas ben non mais c'est vrai parce
qu'il ya mario doit venir
son actionnaire vrai quoi oui est ce que
c'est bien le jeune séquentiel c'est
l'accession à la question alors on va
rappeler ce que c'est que je check on
sait que ça c'est important pour la c1
c'est une méthode qui fait que vous
allez sauter en gros un ou deux repas
dépend du type danse à dire on vous
mangez plus à partir de 18h aideront
mange un jour à 13h voilà exactement
alors ça aujourd'hui d'un point de vue
scientifique il ya beaucoup de gens qui
sont pour beaucoup de gens qui sont
contre moi la seule la seul conseil que
je donne c'est qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
maintenir sur le long terme
moi je suis un farouche partisan de la
routine ça on avait des horloges j'avais
peur j'avais peur qu'en fait ce truc là
où le tiennent à un adieu printrak
exactement c'est ça et puis on en a on a
un rôle social qu'est ce qu'on va faire
quand les restaurants vont rouvrir
et quand vous invite à déjeuner vous dit
non je suis un jeune sans moi je fais
jamais déjeuné chose je sais pas mais en
plus c'est très peu d'amis resteront non
mais non mais non mais non mais non ma
part ça c'est vrai que on se dit ça
c'est ce qu'il ya plein de gens qui font
ça rit ça marche bien mine de rien ça
marche bien ça marche bien
il ya quand même le fait que vous savez
ce qu'on dit aussi c'est que ce qui est
mangé le matin et brûlé ce qui est
manger le soir et stocker d'accord nous
masquons on va se coucher avait donc il
parle il vaut mieux manger le matin que
le soir
ah ben moi je dis vraiment énorme et
l'estomac une mémoire par exemple si
vous sautez un wagon des mémoires
c'est dire si t'aime pas ses mots sur
terre ou de repas il paraît que
l'estomac se rattrape après et rostock
ce que vous lui offrez aux noms prochain
vont pas c'est pas l'estomac qui stocke
c'est vrai c'est pas vrai c'est pas mal
quand même pas mal quand l'art il attend
du batteur sont élus pour faire il faut
savoir qu'on a dans notre cerveau dans
la zone la plus archaïque
on a un petit noyau qui compte les
calories quelle qu'elle soit rapide
glucides protides coillard déjà comme ça
il ya un noyau
il ya un noyau 4 neurones comme une un
batteur de combat en amont qui compte
avec on dira alors tu as pris trois
boulettes comme celui-là des habitudes
parce que lui il est chargé de votre
poids qu'on appelle l' omerta zik c'est
à dire le poison ivy le poids de survie
pas sûr et donc quand on dit dans les
cas des hostas pluie il faisait tout
pour vous pousser à aller chercher
l'alimentation et donc quand vous
arrêtez de manger lui va se mettre en
mode recherche et donc au repas suivant
il veut récupérer les canaris lui il
faut entre neuf mois et un an pour
considérer que le nouveau point est un
poids vivant vivable c'est ça le
problème
l'échec de tous les régimes ce qui fait
dire à quel que soit le régime que vous
faites là se fichent le confinement ça
m'a beaucoup de gens qui ont pris du
poids et wifi demande il ya beaucoup de
gens qui ont pris du poids de
confinement pourquoi parce qu'ils ont
compensé
parce que psychologique moi ça n'a rien
de pire que le conte finir je vous
expliquer pourquoi je vous dis la vérité
j'avais arrêté les granola et bien que
non j'ai repris voilà importante c'est
que ce qu'on a compris avec cette crise
c'est que le seul vrai capital que nous
ayons c'est notre santé c'est vrai c'est
le seul et celui-là on peut pas
l'acheter on peut pas le racheter donc
moi je me bats pour que la prévention
parce qu'il ya des tas de maladies comme
le diabète de type 2 comme les maladies
cardiovasculaires
on pourrait prévenir on a du temps tous
les organes vous prévienne mais vous tu
vas voir si tu continues comme ça tu vas
avoir et on fait rien c'est la
prévention est la caisse 40 fois moins
cher que les amène à faire pour ça pour
savoir pont d'abord il faut tous les
faire un backup
ouais